hi everyone I hope all of you are doing
good thank you very much for signing up
to this d3.js course so what is d 3 d 3
is an open-source JavaScript library
this library may be used to create
visual representations of your data this
means that you can create Dom elements
using your data these Dom elements may
be simple HTML elements like headings
paragraphs buttons or they may include
sophisticated charts and graphs as well
d3 makes use of HTML CSS and SVG to
create those representations and as you
know that these are the technologies of
web so whatever you create using d3 you
can view on any modern browser like
Chrome Firefox Safari or Internet
Explorer this course consists of 10
screencast and I've tried to keep each
screencast short and simple I'll be
explaining fundamental concepts of d3
with the help of simple and interesting
examples to learn more about d3 there
are many good resources available online
the official documentation of d3.js
is also very helpful in this regard
there are also lots of blogs available
about d3 on different platforms like
medium here I've included the links of
couple of blocks first block was written
by me and the other one was written by /
Harrell who is also the co-creator of
this tool scream be' so Who am I I am so
here in Hull I'm a full-stack JavaScript
developer I love traveling reading and
making new friends you can connect me
via Twitter
my handle is given below I hope you
would enjoy this course thank you again
for joining in let's get started
hi there in this lesson we'll be
learning some basic techniques to do the
on selection and manipulation using
d3.js
in our HTML file as you can see that we
have an h1 tag and a couple of script
tags the first script tag is loading
d3.js library from its official link the
other script tag is loading the
JavaScript file in which we'll be
writing all of her d3.js code using d3
we can select Dom elements using their
CSS selectors or the name of element
itself d3 provides us two methods to
select Dom elements they are v3 dot
select and v3 dot select all both of
these methods except a CSS selector or
the name of Dom element as a parameter
and return selection of the element d3
dot select method returns the first
selection of Dom element matching the
criteria while d3 dot select all returns
all the elements matching the criteria
for example if we want to select our
heading tag we can call d3 dot select h1
which will look into the Dom and return
us the first h1 tag it finds if there is
no h1 tag inside the Dom it will return
an empty selection using d3 we can
manipulate a Dom elements as well which
means we can update their style values
or bind data with them for example we
can apply some style to our h1 tag using
dot style method we can give it a
with a save and see that the color of
her heading has been updated in d3 we
can chain methods with each other as
well so that it helps keeping the code
clean and easy to read using dot attr
method we can apply different attributes
to our selected element for example
adding a class or ID to it
we can also update the text of our
selected element using dot text method
we want to appear
Dom elements we can use dot append
method for example we can select our
body element here and append a paragraph
tag we give it a text of first paragraph
we give it a save and see that the
paragraph has been appended to our Dom
let's add couple of more paragraphs
we'll give it a save and see that now we
have three paragraphs inside a Dom let's
select all of these paragraphs using v3
dot select all and give it a style of
color blue we give it a save and see
that the color of our paragraph tags
have been updated to blue in the next
lesson we will be learning some
techniques about data loading and
binding using d3.js thank you for
watching
hi there in the previous lesson we
learned about Dom selection and
manipulation using d3.js
it is time to introduce some data into
the scene using d3 we can map data into
our Dom elements meaning we can append
update or display Dom elements using our
data set in the example we have an array
of some numbers what we are trying to do
here is to create paragraph tags for
each data item in the array we first of
all select our body element using select
method and afterwards we select all the
paragraph tags inside it since we do not
have any paragraph tags yet it will
return an empty selection now we call
dot data method and pass it our data set
as an argument this method will put data
into the waiting state for further
processing we then call dot enter method
this method will take data items one by
one and perform further operations on
them for each data item we are appending
a paragraph tag and binding some dummy
text inside it let's give it a save and
see what appears on the Dom as you can
see that five paragraph tags have been
appended into our Dom each paragraph tag
represents the data item in our data set
we can also update the text of our
paragraphs to show the value of data
item by passing it a function inside the
dot text method this function will be
getting the value of data item in its
parameter which we can return from it
now you see that the paragraphs are
displaying the value of data item inside
it in the next lesson we'll be learning
how to create a bar chart using d3.js
thank you for watching
hello everyone in this lesson we'll be
learning how to create a simple bar job
in our HTML file we have an SVG tag in
our JavaScript file we have our data set
which we will be using to create the bar
chart we have variables defined for the
width and height of SVG container and
the padding between the bars we
calculate the width of each bar by
dividing the total width of SVG
container with the total number of
elements in our data set below that we
select our SVG container and give it the
attribute of width and height next we
will create our bar chart to create a
bar chart we can make use of the fact
that bars are nothing but rectangles so
first of all we select all the
rectangles by using select all method
since we do not have any rectangles in
our SVG so far this will return an empty
selection afterwards we call the data
method and provide it our dataset this
method would take our data set into the
waiting state afterwards we call an
enter method this enter method will take
our data set from the waiting state and
perform further operations this enter
method takes the data from the waiting
State and perform next operations on
each data item so for example it will
call all these methods for 8150 6 and
rest of the data items for each data
item we are appending a rectangle inside
our SVG container we provide the
attribute of Y height width and
transform to each of the rectangle to
give the y attribute we call the
attribute method this takes a function
which gets the data in its parameter we
calculate the Y attribute by subtracting
the data item with the SVG height the
next attribute we set is height we
return the data value from the callback
function
afterwards we provide with to our bar
chart for this we subtract bar padding
from the bar width we calculated in the
beginning in the end we apply the
transformation of translate to our bar
chart so d3 provides us with a lot of
options to transform any object here we
are using the translation kind of
transform for our rectangles so we do
not want our bars to start from the same
position therefore we would want to
translate them one after another and
this is what we are doing over here in
this function in this step we calculate
the value of translation for our bars so
as you can see that there are two values
in this translate array one is the
amount of translation on x-axis and
another one on y-axis since we are
translating each rectangle one after
another
therefore we calculate the value by
multiplying the index with the bar width
in the end we return the translate
string with the value of translation
which we calculated above when we give
it a save we can see that our bar chart
has been appended inside our Dom thank
you very much for watching
hi there in the previous lesson we
learned how to create a bar chart using
d3.js we use the array of numbers as our
data set to create a bar chart in this
lesson we will be applying labels to our
bar chart since labels are text
therefore will be appending a text
element for each data item on top of
each bar like we added rectangles for
our bar chart in the previous example
we'll be adding text element for each
data item for this let's first of all
select all the text element inside our
SVG since we have no text element so far
this will return an empty selection
afterwards we introduce a data set using
data method and get in enter mode using
dot enter method this will bring in
their items one by one for further
processing we want to obtain the text
for each data item and want to keep its
value to be the number itself using text
method we can get the value of our data
item text method either takes a string
or a function as a parameter the
function gets the data value in this
parameter which we can return from
inside it afterwards we give the Y
attribute like we did with our
rectangles above the only difference is
that we want our text to be slightly
higher than our bar and that is why we
are subtracting two more pixels from it
we give the X attribute to be the
starting point of each rectangle and we
get it by using the values of bar width
and index of the data element in the end
we give text element some color by using
the fill attribute we give it a save and
see that labels have been appended on
top of each bar in the next lesson we
will learn how to create scales into our
charts thank you for watching
hi everyone in this lesson we'll be
using the same examples as we used in
our previous two lessons about creating
bar chart and adding labels to them
we now have been reducing a rather
advanced topic which is about using
skills for our data so what are scales
scales are functions which will
transform your data by either increasing
or decreasing their values for better
visualizations so far our bar chart
looks like this what if you upgrade the
data set and introduce much smaller
values hmm so our bars are hardly
visible now this is because the values
which we are using out much smaller in
the scenarios like these we can make use
of the scales here we have created a
variable by the name of Y scale and we
are calling the function of D 3 dot
scale linear we will dent in the method
of dot domain which will take an array
as an argument this array contains two
elements first one is zero and another
one is the maximum number in our data
set we can calculate this number by
using d3 dot max function then we also
change the method of dart range which
will keep the scale values inside the
range of our SVG container
it also takes an array of it the first
element is zero and the second element
is the height of our SVG container now
we finally parse the values of our y
coordinate and the height of the
rectangle using Y scale method and we
give it a save a bars now have been
properly scaled for the visual
representations in the next lesson we
learn how to create accesses inside our
charts thank you for watching
hi guys welcome back to another tutorial
in this lesson we'll be learning about
the concept of axises in d3.js as you
know that accesses are an integral part
of any chart or a graph accesses are
made of lines ticks and text you can
imagine how complicated it would be to
create all three of them separately but
thankfully d3 provides us a very simple
API to create accesses for our charts d3
provides us four significant methods to
create accesses they are d3 dot x stop
XS right X is bottom and X is left let's
learn from a simple example how to
create X and y-axis s for our chart
after selecting our SVG element and
providing it with the attributes of
width and height we move towards
creating scales for our accesses will be
using linear functions to create our
scales we have created scales exactly
like this in our previous lessons as
well so let's move forward moving
forward and now we actually create our
accesses as I mentioned earlier d3
provides us a very simple API to create
accesses for x-axis will be calling d3
dot access bottom this will return a
function which we are going to chain
with another function of a scale and
provide it our X scale similarly to
create a y-axis we call
d3 dot X's left and then chain it with a
scale function and provide it the y
scale afterwards we append a group
element inside our SVG element and
provide it the attribute of crosslet
transformation and then we call y axis
on this group element afterwards we
append another group element inside our
SVG container and provide it the
translate transformation attribute in
the end we call x axis on this group
element
let's give it a safe and we can see that
our accesses have been appended inside
our Dom we can see that our excesses
have lines takes
and text as well and it was all created
just using the access methods provided
by d3 thank you very much for watching
hi there welcome to another lesson of
our d3.js course in this lesson we'll be
learning how to create different SVG
elements using d3 as always in our HTML
file we have an SVG tag and a script
text to load d3.js library and a
javascript file via be right on of our
code SVG or scalable vector graphics is
a powerful tool to define vector
graphics for the web using SVG we can
create different shapes and apply
different styles to them since it's a
vector graphic we can scale them as much
as we want without getting them
distorted in our JavaScript file we
first of all select our SVG element
using d3 dot select and give it the
attribute of width and height we also
give it the attribute of class of SVG
container which we have defined in our
CSS file to create a line using SVG we
need coordinates of a starting and
ending point of a line starting
coordinates would be x1 y1 while ending
coordinates would be x2 y2 these should
be the coordinates inside our SVG
element we also give it the attribute of
a stroke and the stroke will take the
name of any color we give it a save and
see that the line has been rendered
inside our SVG container if we want to
make our lines like a thicker we can
give it the attribute of stroke width it
takes a number and we see that a line
has become a little bit thicker now
let's create a rectangle to create a
rectangle we need to provide X&Y
coordinates which will be the beginning
point of our rectangle we also need to
provide it the attribute of width and
height if we save and refresh we can see
that rectangle has also been rendered
inside our SVG container
it appears purple because we have given
it the attribute of fill with the hash
of a color to create a circle you
Detra dodgiest we need to provide the
coordinates of center of the circle
these coordinates would be CX and CY
also we need to provide the radius of
our circle radius is a distance from
center of a circle to any point on the
boundary of a circuit like rectangle we
can also give it the attribute of fill
if we want to apply any color inside it
now we can see that all of our SVG
elements circle rectangle and line have
been appended inside our SVG container
thank you for watching
hi everyone in this lesson we'll be
creating a pie chart using d3 rjs will
be displaying the market share of top
three operating systems in our budget in
our JavaScript file we have our data set
which is a collection of objects in
which each object contains the name of
the platform and its percentage share we
first of all select our SVG element and
give it the attribute of a width and
height then we move on to creating a
group element inside our SVG container
this group element will hold our pie
chart after appending the group element
which has formed it by translating it to
the center of our SVG container then we
select the range of colors provided by
the built-in method of d3 we will be
using this function to provide colors to
the pies of our chart to prepare our
data to be compatible with drawing pie
chart we pass it through D 3 dot by
method since we want to use the
attribute of percentage from a data set
to create bias we pass a callback
function to D 3 dot pi and return the
percentage attribute now we call D 3 dot
art method which will create path
elements using the arc data we chain
outer radius and inner radius method
which will define the boundaries of
those arcs
know everyone in this last lesson of our
d3.js course will be learning how to
create a line chart we'll be using a
real-time data of Bitcoin price index of
past four months we'll be fetching the
data from an external API and at the end
of this lesson we'll be able to create a
line chart like this so let's get
started in our JavaScript file we have
an API which will be fetching the data
of Bitcoin price index of past four
months below that we have an event
listener which gets fired once the dome
has been loaded in this event listener
we are fetching the data using the API
be declared at the beginning once we
have this data we pass it to another
function which converts this data into
the form which is suitable to create
line chart this function makes an array
of objects in which each object contains
date and the price of Bitcoin on that
particular date once the data has been
parsed we call another function we name
this function draw a chart and pass it
our data this function would be
responsible to create the line chart in
this draw chart function we are getting
a data set in this parameters afterwards
we have defined some variables to
calculate the width and height of the
chart in the next step we select our SVG
element like always and provided the
attributes of width and height then we
append a group tag inside our SVG
element we use attribute method to apply
transformation as an attribute to this
group element even though transform can
accept multiple types of options here we
are keeping it to translation transform
which actually pushes the group over and
down by the amount we are providing over
here then we create scales for our line
chart since we'll be displaying the
price index of Bitcoin over the period
of past few months it makes sense to
display the time duration on the x axis
d3 provides as a function of a scale
time to create such kind of a scales for
a y-axis though it makes sense to keep
the scale linear since we are just
showing the price of Bitcoin on that
axis in the next step we'll create the
line chart we will use the function of
d3 dot line this function
another function which creates the line
next we will change this method to
another function which will set its X
attribute dot X method takes an
anonymous function which gets passed the
data will be returning the attribute of
date for our X attribute please notice
that we are passing the value of date
through our scale method which we have
defined above similarly we will change
the dot Y function to set the Y
attribute we'll be returning the
attribute of value of Bitcoin from this
method after passing it through the Y
scale function the domain function here
is designed to let d3 know about the
scope of the data when it is passed to
scale function if we look at X dot
domain here we are using extent method
to let d3 know about the scope of the
data extent method takes an anonymous
function which returns data value and in
the end it returns minimum and maximum
value of the dates similar things happen
with y dot domain method in which it
returns the minimum and maximum value
this value would be used to create the
scales properly we then append a group
element inside our parent group and
apply some transformations to it then we
pass d3 dot X's bottom function to call
method when we are using the call
function over here we are actually
calling d3 dot X's bottom on a newly
created group element we then select any
classes of domain and remove it moving
forward we append another group element
inside our parent grow and we call the
method of d3 dot X's and left Y on it
afterwards we append some text and pass
them the attributes of fill transform
and some of the coordinates as well this
block of code would basically generate
the y axis in the end we append a path
inside our parent group element this
path would be the line which we see in
the line chart to create this path we
call the method of datum and we pass a
data set we apply some more attributes
like fill stroke stroke width and
provide them the appropriate
values and then in the end we apply the
attribute of D and we pass our line
function over here this line function
would basically be creating the line for
that D attribute in the end we give it a
safe and here you can see that our line
chart has been appended inside our Dom
congratulations you have now completed
the course and have the basic
understanding of d3.js if you have any
questions feel free to reach out to me
via Twitter or in the Q&A section also
if you enjoyed this course I would
appreciate if you would share it here is
the link so feel free to for example
email it to someone you know or share it
on Facebook or Twitter thank you very
much again for watching and good luck
with the coding